สวัสดีค่ะครูเรียมสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูเรียมวัน
นี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันอังคารค่ะค่ะคิดนาน
คิดนานพครูเรียมใส่เสื้อสีชมพูนะคะวันนี้
วันอังคารอือผู้หญิงเห็นเป็นสีชมพูใช่มย
ใช่ค่ะคุเรว่าใส่สีแดงเหมือนสีแดง
นะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันอังคารที่เท่าไหร่
คะวันที่ 20 ค่ะเดือนอะไรคะเดือน
กันยายนอืเป็นเดือนที่ 9 นะคะนักเรียนปี
พ.ศอะไรคะพ.ศ
2565 ค่ะปีค.ศอะไรคะค.ศ
อแล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะตอนนี้ 14 น 56
นาที
อูอีก 4 นาทีก็ 15:00 นแล้วใช่ค่ะรู้สึก
รู้สึกแบบเหมือนวันนี้ฝนจะตกไไม่รู้อ่ะดู
แบบแดดไม่ค่อยมีเลยดูเมฆเยอะๆใช่ค่ะที่
บ้านของเรียมก็เหมือนกันแบบเมฆเยอะมากอื
ช่วงนี้ก็เหมือนพายุเข้าเนาะใช่ค่ะช่วง
นี้ประเทศไทยก็จะช่วงเดือนกันยายนเนี่ยนะ
คะก็จะฝนตกเยอะหน่อยนะคะแต่ก็ยังร้อน
เหมือนเดิมนะคะฝนตกก็ยังร้อนใชใช่ค่ะบาง
ที่ฝนตกแบบเกือบทุกวันก็ยังร้อนอยู่นะอื
อืใช่ค่ะแบบเวลาร้อนก็ไม่อยากอยู่ที่ที่
นึงที่ไม่อยากอยู่เลยอ่ะค่ะเวลาร้อนน่ะ
ค่ะครูเรียมที่ไหนคะไม่อยากอยู่ที่บ้าน
ของเรานี่แหละค่ะออออเมนึกว่าที่บ้านนี่
อยู่แล้วสบายที่สุดนไม่ค่ะที่ห้างค่ะสบาย
ที่สุดค่ะเพราะแอร์เย็น
อืแอร์ฟรีแอร์ฟรไปเดินห้างสิคะครูเรี่มมี
แอร์เย็น
สบายความจริงแล้วเราก็ไปได้หลายที่มากเลย
นะครูหิงอืใช่ค่ะเดมก็เลยคิดว่าวันนี้เอา
มาทำเป็นเกมดีกว่า
อสถานที่เนี่ยนะคะเอามาทำเป็นเกมยังไงจะ
เล่นยังไงคะครูเรียมจะให้ครูหญิงกับครู
เรียมไปห้างไปภูเขาไปที่ต่างๆหรอคะเราไม่
ต้องไปจริงๆค่ะครูหญิงอ๋อเราแค่คิดเรียม
จะคิดแบบสถานที่มา 1 สถานที่แล้วให้เรา
ตอบแบบไม่ซ้ำกันว่าเราไปทำอะไรที่นั่นอ๋อ
ห้ามตอบเหมือนกันด้วยใช่มั้ยคะใช่อออ้า
แล้วใครใครจะตอบก่อนใครจะตอบหลัง
อ่ะเตรมว่าเป่ายิ้งฉุบเป่ายิ้งฉุบดีกว่า
เป่ายิ้งชุบใครชนะตอบ
ก่อนใช่
ๆได้เลยค่ะครูเรียมโอเคผู้หญิงไปนี่คือ
พร้อมมั้ยคะพร้อมค่ะครูเรียมสถานที่แรก
ที่ครูเรียมจะไปสถานที่แรกก็คือสถานี
ตำรวจโอหสถานีตำรวจเราต้องเป่ายิ้งฉุบใช่
มยใช่คนที่ชนะจะได้ตอบก่อนสีตำรวจไปทำ
เรื่องเยอะแยะมาดูกันว่าไปทำอะไรได้บ้า
เป่ายิงยิงฉุบฉุบผู้หญิงเอาอะไรกรรไกร
เหรอโอเคอีกครั้งนึงเป่ายิ้งชุบเป่ายิ้ง
ชุบแผู้หญิงไม่จบมาเอาไเ่ายิเ่ายชุบชุบออ
ใครชนะชนะเย้ครูหญิงตอบก่อนครูหญิงจะบอก
ว่าไปแจ้งความ
อืก็
คืออะไรดีล่ะครูหญิงเนี่ยอาจจะเดิน
ช้อปปิ้งอยู่อืแล้วก็เพลินมีคนเนี่ยขโมย
กระเป๋าเงินของครูหญิงไปครูหญิงก็ไม่มี
บัตรประชาชน ID การ์ดบัตรเครดิตทุกอย่าง
หายหมดเลยครูหญิงก็ต้องไปที่สถานีตำรวจ
แล้วก็ไปแจ้งความไปบอกตำรวจว่าสวัสดีค่ะ
ตำรวจคือหนูกระเป๋าสตางคหายอ่ะค่ะที่สยาม
พารากอนเวลา 14:00 นค่ะนี่คือไปแจ้งความ
อืแล้วครูเรียมหรอคะครูเรียมตอบเหมือนครู
หญิงไม่ได้นะครูเรียมจะบอกว่าไปแจ้งความ
ที่สถานีตำรวจไม่ได้นะคะครูหญิงตอบเลย
แล้วโอเคเดี๋ยวเรียมเรียมตอบบ้างเรียมก็
ไปจ่ายค่าปรับไงคะครูหญิงยังไงคะจ่ายค่า
ปรับเวลาที่เรียมขับรถมอเตอร์ไซค์ไม่ใส่
หมวกกันน็อคเนี่ยเรียมก็จะได้รับใบสั่งมา
อืตำรวจก็จะเขียนสครูเรียมไม่ใส่หมวกกัน
น็อต้องจ่ายเงินกี่บาทออ 200 บาทเรมก็
ต้อง 200 บาทเอาเนี่ยเอาเค้าเรียกว่าอะไร
ใบสั่งใบสั่งเอาใบสั่งไปสถานีตำรวจแล้วก็
จ่ายเงินนี่อ่าไปจ่ายค่าปรับเฮเห็นมั้ย
หอกแล้วสถานีตำรวจมีเยอะพอแล้วเนาะคนละ 1
ก็พอใช่มั้ยคิดไม่ได้แล้วนะคะคิดไม่ออก
แล้วนะไม่ๆๆครูหญิงมีอีกมั้ย
โอหรือว่าครูหญิงจะยอม
แพ้อ๋อก็คือเล่นไปเรื่อยๆจนกว่าจะคิดไม่
ออกอ่ะหรอไปสถานีตำรวจ
สสตำรวจไปทำอะไรอีกอ่ะไปแจ้งความไปจ่าย
ค่าปราบครูเรรียนบอกว่าไปใจพสันนี้ตำรวจ
ไปทำอะไรอีกอ่ะอๆคิดไม่ออก
อ่ะผู้
หญิงไปทำอะไรคะครูเรียมเรียมว่าไปทำอะไร
ได้อีกหลายอย่างเลยนะครูหญิงครูหญิงเป็น
คนพูดเองนะโอ้ไปสันนิตำรวจไปทำอะไรได้
เยอะแยะเลยคิดออก 1 อย่างแจ้งผู้หญิงจะ
ยอมแพ้จริงๆเหรอผู้หญิงคิดไม่ออกอ่ะเราไป
ทำอะไรที่สถานีตำรวจอีกอ่ะนอกจากเราไป
แจ้งความกับไปจ่ายค่าปรับผู้หญิงยอมแพ้
มั้ยเดี๋ยวเรียมเล่าให้ฟังว่าทำอะไรได้
อีกเ้าไป
เยี่ยมเยี่ยม
อะไรสมมุติว่าเรามีเพื่อนโดนตำรวจจับอยู่
ที่สถานีตำรวจเราก็ไปเยี่ยมเ้าไงซื้อข้าว
ผัดกับน้ำไปให้เค้าออได้มได้ๆๆไปเยี่ยม
เพื่อนไปเยี่ยมแบบเหมือนคนที่เรารู้จัก
ใช่มเติดคุก
อืความจริงตำรความจริงก็ไม่อยากให้เกิด
ขึ้นนะแต่ว่าแบบไม่อยากเกิดขึ้นไม่อยาก
ให้เกิดขึ้นแต่นี่คือบอกเฉยๆว่าเราไปไป
เยี่ยมคนที่ติดคุกอยู่ในสถานีตำรวจได้แบบ
มันจะเป็นความผิดเล็กๆน้อยๆอะไรอย่าง
เงี้ยค่ะอ่ะแล้วครูเรียมล่ะคะสถานีตำรวจ
ทำอะไรได้อีกไปทำอะไรได้อีกที่สถานีตำรวจ
มีห้องน้ำเรียนก็ขอเข้าห้องน้ำหน่อยนะคะ
ใชแต่ผู้หญิงก็เคยนะผู้หญิงก็เคยไปเข้า
ห้องน้ำที่สถานีตำรวจใช่นี่ไงออครูหญิง
ล่ะทำอะไรได้อีกมั้ยไปหาแฟนไงคะแฟนเป็น
ตำรวจใช่มีแฟนแฟนเป็นตำรวจเราก็ไปหาแฟน
ที่ทำงานอยู่ที่สถานีตำรวจได้ไหม
ได้เออแล้วไปทำอะไรได้อีกคะครู
เรียมเรียมกำลังแบบหัวเราะกับความคิดของ
เรียมเรียมก็แบบไปติดคุก
ไงอ้าูหญิงค้างไปอ่ะฮัลโหลฮัลโหลมา
แล้วอยู่ดีๆอินเทอร์เน็ตก็หลุดไปเลยหญิง
ได้แค่ถามครูเรียนเสร็จถามครูเรียนว่าเรา
ไปทำอะไรได้อีกแล้วก็บอกเอทำไมครูเรียม
คิดนานจังเราก็หันมาเอ้ามันค้างคิดว่า
เน็ตเราแน่ๆใชออเรียมเห็นผู้หญิงค้างไป
เลยเ้าใช่โอเคค่ะก็ครูหญิงเนี่ยไปหาแฟน
แล้วอืครูเรียมคะไปทำอะไรได้อีกคะที่
สถานีตำรวจเรียมก็อยากคิดเรื่องดีๆนะแต่
ตอนนี้แบบเรียมปิ๊งขึ้นมาได้
ว่าถ้าเรียมทำความผิดอ่ะเรียมก็ไปติดคุก
ไงแบบอ๋อไม่ได้ไปเยี่ยมใครใช่มยก็คือเรา
โดนตำรวจจับไปที่สถานีตำรวจ
อืไปติดคุกที่สถานีตำรวจแต่ข้อนี้ทำให้
เรียมรอดทำให้เรียมตอบคำถามครูหญิงได้อ้า
ครูหญิงไปทำอะไรอีกมั้ยไปทำอะไรอีกอ่ะที่
สถานี
ตำรวจอันนี้มันเหมือนกันมอ่ะมันก็คือการ
แจ้งความใช่มยเวลาเราไปบอกตำรวจว่าวันนี้
เกิดอะไรมันก็ต้องเป็นการแจ้งความใช่มั้ย
คะจยอมแพ้ก็ได้
นะไม่ได้ค่ะเราไม่อยากยอมแพ้เราเป็นคน
เล่นเกมเราต้อง
ชนะไปไปไปรับรถที่ถูก
ยึดได้มเอ้าบางครั้งอ่ะเราอาจจะแบบรถของ
เรามันไม่โอเคไงคะไม่รู้อ่ะเราโดนตำรวจ
เรียกแล้วตำรวจก็เอารถของเราเนี่ยไปไว้
ที่สถานีตำรวจพอพรุ่งนี้เราก็ต้องไปรับรถ
ของเราที่สถานีตำรวจได้มั้ยได้ๆๆๆแต่ทำ
ให้ครูเรียมคิดออกเลยอ่ะใชเรียมคิดออก
แล้วว่าจะทำอะไรไปทำอะไรคะครูเรียมเรียม
ก็จะไปประมูลของที่อยู่ในสถานีตำรวจอุย
ยังไงอ่ะประมูลได้นะแบบพวกรถหรือว่าของ
บางอย่างที่แบบตำรวจแบบเหมือนเเอาไปจากคน
ที่แบบทำผิดแล้วเโดนจับใช่มั้ยยค่ะมีของ
พวกรถมอเตอร์ไซค์หรือว่ารถยนต์เราก็
เหมือนแบบไปจ่ายเงินน้อยๆเค้าเรียกว่าแบบ
ไปประมูลอ๋อแบบว่าอ้า 500 อ่ะครุเมก็บอก
520 ครูหญิงก็บอก 540 อันนี้คือการ
ประมูลใช่ไปประมูลของได้เหมือนรถ
มอเตอร์ไซค์อ่ะู้หญิงไม่มาเอาเค้าก็จะเอา
ออกมาประมูลเดมก็ออไปประมูลอืเออแบบมี
เงินไปซื้ออ่ะเอออืแต่คุณหญิงคิดไม่ออก
แล้วอ่ะค่ะยอมแพ้แล้วอ่ะสถานีตำรวจเย้นัก
เรียนตลกอกเหรอุเรียนมีอีกเหรอนิมก็คิด
ไม่ออกแล้วเหมือนกันดีที่ครูหญิงยอมแพ้
ก่อนอพอแล้วสถานีตำรวจอ่ะคิดไม่ออกแล้ว
อ่ะใช่ๆคิดไม่ออกแล้วต่อไปเดี๋ยวดูเวลา
ก่อน 56 ใช่มย
56 โอเคโอเค
อีก 10 นาทีต่อไปสถานที่ก็คือตลาด
อูตลาดไปซื้อปลาค่ะตอบก่อนเลยไม่ต้องเป่า
ยิ้งฉุบเหอเอ้อผู้หญิงไม่เป่ายิ้งฉุบหรอ
ผู้หญิงแบบรีบมากโเเป่า
หยิงชุบชุบปะผู้หญิงออกนี่ผู้หญิงออกนี่
เป่ายิชุบชุบเป่าเป่าเยชุบบบโอเคครูเรียม
ตอบก่อนห้ามไปซื้อปลานะนี่ของครูหญิงเอ้า
อ่ะคืออะไรคือ
อะไรครูหญิงเรียนได้เราไปทำอะไรเราไปทำ
อะไรที่ตลาดคะครูเรียมครูเรียมเได้สิทธิ์
ตอบก่อนไปเป็นแม่ค้าค่ะไปขายของอก็คือไป
อ้าไปขายของครูหญิงก็คือไปเป็นลูกค้าค่ะ
ไปซื้อของแล้วก็ไปซื้อปลาซื้อหมูซื้อไก่
ซื้อผักซื้อทุกอย่างเลยพูดหมดแล้วนะคะพูด
ต่อไม่ได้แล้วดีมากดีมากฉลาด
มากแล้วทำอะไรได้อีกคะที่ตลาดเรียมก็ไป
เข็นรถเข็นอ่ะเออเข็นรถเข็นแล้วก็เออไปทำ
งานเข็นรถเข็นในตลาดอือครูหญิงก็ไปส่งของ
ที่ตลาดไงคะเ้าเป็นลูกค้าใช่มยแตู่้หญิง
เนี่ยที่บ้านเนี่ยจับปลาครูหญิงก็เอาปลา
ที่จับได้เนี่ยไปส่งให้แม่ค้าก็คือครู
เรียมขายที่
ตลาดไม่ได้ไปซื้อของนะเอาของไปส่ง
อืสุด
ยอดมาเรียมรู้ละเรียมเห็นที่ตลาดที่ตลาด
จะมีคนร้อง
เพลงขอทานเหรอคะคุณไปขอเงินที่
ตลาดความจริงก็มีนะมีแบบมีแบบขอทานก็มี
แบบที่แบบร้องเพลงแล้วก็ขอเงินแต่ว่ามัน
จะมีแบบคนที่แบบร้องเพลงแล้วก็ขอเงิน
บริจาคเพื่อโรงเรียนหรือว่าร้องเพลงขอ
เงินบริจาคเพื่อโรงพยาบาลอืครูเรียมก็จะ
ไปร้องเพลงแบบนั้นใช่ๆๆครูหญิงทำอะไร
อีกไปขับตุ๊กๆที่
ตลาดตลาดเราต้องมีรถตุ๊กๆนะคะเพราะว่าแม่
ค้าที่เค้าซื้อหมูซื้อเป็ดซื้อไก่ซื้อ
อาหารทะเลเนี่ยเค้าจะไม่เอาขึ้นรถแท็กซี่
หรืออะไรอย่างงี้หรอกนะถ้ากรุงเทพฯอ่ะนะ
เค้าก็จะต้องขึ้นรถตุ๊กๆก็ไปขับตุ๊กๆที่
ตลาดค่ะอืได้ได้ๆมีอีกมั้ยคะครูเหลี่ยม
เรียมไปขับวิน
มอเตอร์ไซค์ผู้หญิงไม่อยากจะพูดว่าขับวิน
มอเตอร์ไซค์ไงไปขับวินมอเตอร์ไซค์นี่
ได้แล้วก็ต
เ้อ
จลาดไปซื้อออคิดไม่ออกอ่ะครูเรียมเค้านำ
อยู่ใช่มยเพราะว่าผู้หญิงเป็นคนตอบคนที่ 2
อ่ะผู้หญิงยอมแพ้ก็ได้เไปทำอะไรที่ตลาดไป
เดินเล่นค่ะไม่ไปซื้อของไปเดินเที่ยวที่
ตลาดทำไมอ่ะได้นะนักเรียนเป็นคนต่างชาติ
มาประเทศไทยอ่ะอยากจะไปดูว่าตลาดไทยเป็น
ยังไงก็ไปเดินเที่ยวที่ตลาดอืได้มั้ยคะ
ได้ๆๆๆๆอืครูเรียมคะมีมั้ยคะทำอะไรที่
ตลาดเรียมก็ไปแบบกวาดทำความสะอาดตลาดอืม
เป็นเหมือนพนักงานทำความสะอาดค่ะเออเพราะ
ว่าตลาดแบบสกปรกอ่ะเราก็ต้องเป็นคนดีไง
เราก็ไปทำงานแล้วก็แบบกวาดล้างตลาดอือื
ได้ๆได้ๆอันนี้ก็ไปเก็บเงินค่ะเป็นเจ้า
ของตลาดแล้วก็ครูเรียมจ่ายมาจ่ายมาเดือน
นี้ 500 บาทค่าเช่าตลาดขายของนี่ไงไปเก็บ
เงินว่าเป็นเจ้าของตลาด
เย้อุยไม่ทำอะไรอเครูเรียมไปทำอะไรอีกคะ
ที่
ตลาดไปทำอะไรอ่ะโอ๊ยนึกนึก
โหนี่เราก็ทำมาหลายอย่างแล้วนะนึกไม่
ออกโอ๊ยนึกไม่ออกไปทำอะไรอีกที่
[เพลง]
ตลาดนึกไม่นี่ไงครูหญิงคิดออกครูเรียมอ
อ่ะครูหญิงจะตอบให้เรียมเหรอใช่ทำไมตอบ
ให้ครูหญิงเองสิเออครูเรียมคิดไม่ออกก็ก็
ก็ครูเรียมก็ข้ามไ้ก่อนครูหญิงก็คิด
ออก
ขายของซื้อของกวาด
ตลาดก็ทำทุกอย่างตลาดขับรถขับเงินร้อง
เพลงมีอีกอย่างนึงผู้หญิงเนี่ยเป็นคนที่
แบบว่ามีครอบครัวทำงานที่ตลาดนะคะหืไม่
น่าถามเรื่องตลาด
เลยเ้อยอมแพ้ก็ได้ยอมแพ้ยอมแพ้ไปเป็น
เพื่อนแม่คค้าไงไปช่วยแม่ขายของไปช่วยพี่
ขายของเราไม่ได้เป็นแม่ค้าเราไม่ได้ไป
เป็นลูกค้าแต่เราไปช่วยเขาขายของไงครู
เรียมครูหญิงเคยผหญิงก็ไม่ได้เหรอผู้หญิง
แบบนี้ก็ได้เหรอได้เออได้มากกว่าไปเดิน
เที่ยวที่ตลาดอีกผู้หญิงตอบไปก่อนเออ
เรียมงงแบบเรียมแบบว้าวกับคำตอบู้หญิงมาก
ๆไม่ครูเรียมแต่เขามีคนที่แบบว่าไปเที่ยว
ตลาดจริงๆนะไปเที่ยวจริงๆอ่ะเออแบบไป
เพื่อไปเที่ยวอ่ะไปดูว่ามันเป็นยังไงไงไป
เที่ยวเออแต่ว่าอาจจะเคยนะใช่ค่ะหรือว่า
เราสมมุติครูหญิงไปไปเที่ยวจังหวัดอะไร
สักจังหวัดนึงอ่ะเราก็อยากไปเที่ยวตลาดนะ
อาจจะไม่ได้ไปซื้อหมูซื้อไก่มาทำอาหารน่ะ
แต่ไปเที่ยวไงใช่บางคนก็ไปเที่ยวแล้วไป
ถ่ายรูปอ้อตลาดประเทศไทย
ใช่ค่ะอันนี้ก็ไปช่วยเพื่อนไปช่วยแม่ไป
ช่วยป้าขายของอืคุเรียมมีคิดออกอีกมั้ยคะ
ตลาดไม่ทำอะไรอผู้หญิงก็าบเรียมก็ไม่รู้
นะแบบเรียมก็คิดอยู่นะแต่เรียมไม่รู้ว่า
ตลาดที่อื่นเป็นเหมือนตลาดแบบใกล้ๆบ้าน
เหลี่ยมหรือเปล่าที่ในตลาดแถวบ้านเหลี่ม
อ่ะเขาจะมีร้านเสริมสวย
อืบางที่มีแบบตลาดใหญ่ๆหน่อยอ่ะตลาดที่
เป็นแบบที่ไม่ใช่เป็นตลาดแล้วก็มีแผงแผง
ขายปลาขายหมูอ่ะตลาดที่เป็นเหมือนมีบ้าน
คนน่ะใช่ไหมแล้วมันจะมีใช่ๆมีค่ะมีแต่อัน
นี้ก็มีทั้งขายปลาขายหมูขายผักแล้วก็มี
ร้านเสริมสวยด้วยนะอื้อๆคือแต่เรียมไม่
รู้ว่าที่อื่นเมีหรือเปล่าชาบ้านหญชาว
บ้านู้หญิงก็มีค่ะมีแบบบางครั้งเขาก็จะมี
แบบทางเข้าตลาดตรงนี้ใช่มั้ยมันก็จะมี
ร้านเสริมสวยแล้วก็เดินเข้าไปไปในตลาดก็
จะเป็นตลาดที่ขายของเยอะๆใช่คุณเก็คิดว่า
จะไปทำผมเหรอคะใช่จะไปทำผมก็ได้หรือว่าจะ
ไปเปิดร้านเสริมสวยแล้วก็ให้ลูกค้าเข้ามา
ทำผมให้ลูกค้ามาสระผมอืก็ได้ค่ะได้ๆโอเค
ครูหญิงคิดไม่ออกแล้วค่ะครูหญิงคิดว่านัก
เรียนจะแบบคิดได้เยอะกว่าเรามั้ยหรือว่า
นักเรียนแบบไม่รู้เหือนกันเพราะว่าเราก็
ไม่รู้ว่าตลาดประเทศนักเรียนน่ะไปทำอะไร
ได้อีกไงเฮ้ยอันนี้ก็ได้นะครูเรียมไปกิน
ก๋วยเตี๋ยวที่ตลาดคือตลาดที่บ้านครูหญิง
อ่ะตลาดที่บ้านูหญิงอ่ะมีก๋วยเตี๋ยวขายไง
มีมีแบบเป็นมันคือตลาดเใหญ่มากๆอ่ะค่ะมัน
ก็จะมีเดินผ่านเข้าไปข้างในตรงนี้ก็จะขาย
หมูขายไก่ขายผักพอเดินเข้าไปข้างในก็จะมี
ร้านก๋วยเตี๋ยวเราก็ไปนั่งกินก๋วยเตี๋ยว
ก่อนแล้วเราก็ค่อยไปซื้อของที่ตลาดก็ได้
ใช่ใช่เรียมก็ไปบ่อยๆนะตลาดที่บ้านก็ไป
กินอาหารเช้าอ่ะอเ้าตลาดเจะเปิดเช้าแล้ว
เอ้อเราไปกินไปกินอยู่ที่ตลาดไปดื่มกาแฟ
ไปดื่มกาแฟตอนเช้าที่ตลาดใช่ๆโอความจริง
ก็มีหลายอย่างมากเลยนะอืแล้วก็พูดไม่หมดข
ของที่ตลาดเออใช่ๆๆใช่โมย
เขานี่ไงเพราะว่าไปขโมยของที่ตลาดใช่มั้ย
เออไปล้วงกระเป๋าไปล้วงกระเป๋าเออเริ่ม
ไม่ดีกระเป๋าที่ตลาดเสร็จแล้วก็ไปแจ้ง
ความที่สถานีตำรวจนะคะไม่แจ้งความก็แบบไป
ติดคุกเออไปติดคุกแบบครูเลียมบอกเดี๋ยว
ผู้หญิงก็ซื้อของไปฝากที่เพื่อนที่ติดคุก
ที่ตลาดอย่างงี้นะคะเอ้ยที่ตลาดที่สถานี
ตำรวจเริ่มงงแล้วอ่ะสงสัยต้องไปตลาดแล้ว
อ่ะค่ะครูเียมต้องไปหาซื้ออาหารกินแล้ว
ล่ะค่ะน่าจะเริ่มหิวแล้วอ่ะอืคิดว่าวัน
นี้นักเรียนก็คงจะได้เรียนรู้ไปเยอะเลย
แหละว่าแบบไปสถานีตำรวจทำอะไรได้บ้างไป
ตลาดทำอะไรได้บ้างอืนอกจากที่แบบไปปกติ
ใช่มั้ยเพราะว่าครูหญิงกับครูเรียมก็ไป
ไม่ธรรมดานะคะไปเที่ยวตลาดไปบปกิไปขโมย
ของที่
ตลาดไม่ดีไม่ดีนะอย่าทำนะคะเพราะว่าถ้าไป
ขโมยเสร็จแล้วอาจจะต้องไปที่สถานีตำรวจนะ
คะส่วนวดีโอนี้คิดว่ามันหมดเวลาแล้วใช่
มั้ยคะครูเรียมเรา 2 คนจะไปตลาดดีกว่านะ
คะอ๋อนึกว่าไปสถานีตำรวจไปค่ะไม่ไปอัน
นั้นไม่สนุกค่ะไปตลาดสนุกกว่านะคะแล้ว
เดี๋ยวเรามาเจอกันใหม่ในวีีดีโอหน้านะคะ
สำหรับวันนี้ต้องลาไปก่อนค่ะสวัสดี
ค่ะบ๊ายบายบ๊าย
[เพลง]
บาย